could could all this be related to the
crisis in art
well i don't know whether you mean the
crisis since 1905 or 1975
or which
well
i i'm not it's not exactly a crisis
art the goal of art is to be
incomprehensible or a portion of it has
to be incomprehensible i think that you
know these paintings at losco and
altamira which are now dated at 19 000
years old
when the first ones were discovered in
the 1890s
they were thought to be
400 to 500 years old and as
it dawned on people what this was and
this was like 1905 to 1925 it just
the abyss of time and history that
opened up for people who were sensitive
to it the realization that you know my
god people have been feeling what i've
been feeling thinking what i've been
feeling for at least 20 000 years and
this impacted on picasso
it impacted on miro it impacted on clay
it impacted on marcel duchamp all of
these people and much of the of the bad
boy antics of modern art is actually
it's when you bring a primitive home to
dinner you know when the 19th century
academy brings home a savage from the
south sea island marshall marcel de
champion insisting on wearing a
toilet thing around his neck at certain
formal occasions
if they were and for instance in the
punk the current punk phenomenon of body
painting you know they would be
perfectly at home in the mountains of
new guinea people love to paint
themselves this was very big before the
last ice age
and you know if you if you believe heavy
metal sets fashion it looks like it's
going to be very big in the next century
uh
but a more serious answer to your
question is i think that the the crisis
is not
it depends it's a crisis it's an
opportunity what it is is that art is
becoming
eschatological
the from uh
um ducheon on
from the close of the medieval period on
art was conceived of a series of
self-transcending styles
moving toward various goals which
usually derived from the philosophy of
the time
and
beginning
you know so that realism or mannerism
these various tendencies would be
pursued what's happened in the 20th
century with the legitimizing of
experience
and the
and the legitimizing of experiment and
the destruction of the patronage system
in the academy is that everything
happens there are people painting in new
york today in the style of jan van ike
and making a living at it and there are
also
people doing all kinds of things but
it's very very hard to pick out a new
piece of art if by
i don't think
well the art of the last 20 years has
been art outside of time
since the middle 60s since william wiley
and funk and all that stuff began
it's impossible to date art objects they
can have been made anytime in the last
20 years this is what eschatological
time will be like a transcendence of
style and people simply working in these
various modes of self-expression which
compete in a great a temporal carnival
wherein unfortunately the values of the
marketplace
play too great a role but no other way
of mediating it has been found part of
what's happened to art is that it's been
transformed into an enormous industry
that must produce objects to decorate
the apartments of the affluent on all
continents who want to
you know
have art and be involved in art but they
are not they don't have enough power to
dictate style they'll take whatever is
put before them
which is very liberating for artists
all magic is technology that's what
clark was saying and on another level
all technology is magic
you know it's not for nothing that that
huge special effects company called
itself industrial light and magic
you know it's an understanding
the the mundane the industrial the
capital-based can still be combined with
the magical no i might be i don't know
you know spirit
my hope is that what these communication
technologies will make more accessible
to us and more
uh
corporeal paradoxically is our own
imaginations
that we need to
show each other the inside of our own
heads
and build art i mean
my conviction of this comes from the
fact that i know a lot about art
probably you do too i you know spend
time with it go to museums think about
it so far and so on and there's more art
in my head
joe ordinary
than there is in
half the museums on this planet well how
then it's it's what's maddening is how
narrow the reduction valve is you know
we've been making art for 5 000 years
and what have we got we've got a few
museums full of some nice stuff but what
have we got in our heads
50 000 times more good stuff
but very hard to get out
and really hard to get out when you're
carving it in diorite and granite and
you know
but
somehow this
barrier between us and these realms of
art you don't even have to talk
philosophy you don't have to call it
the platonic realm of ideas or or
some higher imperium you just have to
say beauty there's a great deal of
beauty on the other side of this tiny
keyhole that we're looking through and
if technology gives us a way to open the
door and all waltz through dancing
it seems to me that would be a spiritual
renaissance that what happens at a
spiritual renaissance is by some means
the collective soul
becomes collectively known
like in the italian renaissance the
invention of oil painting allowed
great geniuses to portray
the major themes moving in the
archetypal unconscious of their patrons
and the populations who viewed their
paintings and themselves
and it
it's a shared epiphany it's a spiritual
quest it's a group transformation but
it's it's driven by and led by the
revelation
of art
[Music]
you